ils étaient quelques milliers de
manifestants au plus fort de la
manifestation à avoir répondu présent à
l'appel du plusieurs dizaines
d'organisations syndicales politiques et
d'associations pour protester contre les
idées et la candidature d'eric zemmour à
la prochaine élection présidentielle
rassemblement qui a débuté en début
d'après midi du côté de barbès et qui
s'est achevée ici même quelques heures
plus tard du côté de la villette la
ville est c'était le lieu initialement
prévu par le polémiste pour organisons
sont organisé son premier meeting de
campagne avant de modifier ce lieu pour
et bien choisir le parc des expositions
de villepinte pour des mesures de
sécurité dit son entourage on a
interrogé quelques manifestants au début
de ce cortège vous propose de les
écouter on manifeste aujourd'hui par
rapport aux idées qui sont en train de
se propager
au-delà de zemmoura seymour et les
autres et qui sont des idées
effectivement
racisme
la première des raisons racistes et
xénophobes
sexistes
voilà parce qu'on entend beaucoup de
choses si là dessus et moi
personnellement je viens d'une famille
qui a connu
les persécutions et donc je suis là
parce que je suis atterré
j'aurais jamais pensé en tant que ça en
fait c'est goldman va des mesures et ce
qui se passe c'est que le vt de se
réunir ensemble
dans un groupe i contre sembas a redonné
un peu de la force aussi et ça prend du
recul et au sodium ou hockey dans tout
le monde ne pense pas comme ça est ok
oui il ya des gens qui trouvent que
c'est complètement faux pour les neuf
mois et que ça n'a aucun sens et c'est
pas normal enfin c'est insupportable
cette hégémonie qu'il a dans les médias
- c'est ça qui il peut se présenter je
veux dire mais juste que je ne comprends
pas c'est cette hégémonie dans les
médias pourquoi au nom de quoi il est il
est partout au nom de quoi un
rassemblement qui s'est déroulé sans
heurts sans débordement particulier
malgré les craintes elle des autorités
américaines à l'ambassade américaine de
paris avait conseillé à ses
ressortissants de ne pas se rendre dans
plusieurs secteurs d'île de france à
savoir barbès la villette et villepinte
où se déroulait justement à des
manifestations contre le polémiste
contre sa candidature
ce rassemblement s'est bien déroulé un
dispositif de sécurité était assez
imposant même s'il était plutôt discret
les forces de l'ordre se sont postés par
sécurité par mesure de précaution à
plusieurs dizaines de mètres du cortège
des manifestants ici présents qui est
bien souhaite continuer à protester
contre eric zemmour et la diffusion de
ses idées d'extrême droite ils ont
d'ailleurs prévu de retourner manifester
dans les rues de la capitale ce sera
samedi prochain